ein fall für den verfassungsschutz teile
der querdenken bewegungen werden jetzt
bundesweit beobachtet ein land macht
wieder auf die niederlande öffnen leben
und außengastronomie trotz viel höherer
infektionszahlen als bei uns und trotz
voller intensivstation
ein aufruf der helfen kann
erwachsene die früher in der schule
missbraucht wurden sollen sich einer
neuen expertengruppe an vertrauen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann dabei ein schönes land
davon seit einem jahr macht sie mobil
gegen die korona maßnahmen des staates
die querdenken bewegung ihr spektrum ist
breit und umfasst impfgegner wie reichs
bürger/innen rechtsextreme und esoterik
fans weil ihr protest sich zuletzt immer
stärker radikalisierte und auch
gewalttätig wurde hat sich jetzt der
verfassungsschutz entschlossen die
bewegung bundesweit zu beobachten
die querdenken bewegung passt nicht in
die kategorien mit denen der
verfassungsschutz bislang arbeitet etwa
rechts oder links extremismus oder
islamismus
deshalb wurde für sie nun eine neue
kategorie geschaffen verfassungsschutz
relevante delegitimierung des staates
einzelne gruppen und personen innerhalb
der querdenken bewegungen will die
behörde jetzt mit
nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
beobachten
klaus brodbeck berichtet darum geht es
extremisten die versuchen corona
proteste für sich zu vereinnahmen
um die rechtmäßigkeit des staats nicht
selten gar den staat selbst in zweifel
zu ziehen
immer dann wenn die extremisten die
bühne betreten und versuchen sich solche
bewegungen zu bemächtigen oder wenn
gewalt im spiel ist dann gilt unser
grundsatz null toleranz wer den staat
und dessen organe etwa parlamente
verächtlich macht oder gar zum aktiven
widerstand aufruft kann nun auch vom
verfassungsschutz des bundes
nachrichtendienstlich beobachtet werden
bis hin zum anwerben von v-leuten oder
der überwachung von kommunikation dass
man da jetzt genauer hinguckt nach all
dem was passiert ist nach all den
problematischen tendenzen die zu
beobachten waren die letzten monate
das ist folgerichtig und jetzt schauen
wir was in den nächsten monaten passiert
bei der beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz geht es nicht um
menschen die kritische fragen stellen
sondern es geht um die tatsache dass die
querdenken bewegung von rechtsextremen
verschwörungstheoretiker zutiefst
durchdrungen ist grenzen sind da wo
extreme meinungen in gewalt umschlage
gewaltbereitschaft gewalt befürworten
das ist etwas was unser staat nicht mehr
tolerieren kann ausdrücklich nicht
betroffen hingegen alle die einfach nur
mit der korona politik der regierenden
unzufrieden sind und das auch laut zum
ausdruck bringen ihr gutes recht dass
müssen staat und politik raushalten
gemeinsam gegen das virus kämpfen oder
jeder für sich allein die mühsam
erreichte bundes notbremse mit
einheitlichen krone regeln greift seit
gerade mal fünf tagen und schon läuft es
wieder auseinander
in der aktuellen debatte um mehr
freiheiten für geimpfte fordern etliche
bundesländer mehr tempo von der
bundesregierung und preschen schon mal
voran
nicht alle finden es einfach da noch zu
folgen an seinem stern im friseursalon
von marie falkenstein in mainz gab es
heute eine menge verwirrung was gilt für
kunden die den vollen impfschutz haben
den tag über sagte die stadtverwaltung
nämlich etwas anderes als die
landesregierung seit dem späten
nachmittag ist aber klar der zweifach
geimpft ist braucht hier keinen
negativen corona test mehr rheinland
pfalz eines der länder das hier fakten
schafft das auf jeden fall sein darf
muss dass sie ihre rechte wieder
bekommen das haben anfangs schwierig es
in der situation und die politiker wie
gesagt ihr eigenes süppchen kochen
länder die vorpreschen bundes
verordnungen die in arbeit sind viel ist
unklar
die bundesjustizministerin verspricht
sie wollen nun schnell handeln
das wäre ein falsches signal wenn wir
uns da von gerichten treiben lassen
würden sondern wir müssen handlungsfähig
sein ich werde unverzüglich
schnellstmöglich jetzt eine verordnung
vorlegen unverzüglich auch hier viele
fragen laut bundesgesundheitsministerium
soll bis zum 28
mai eine bundesweite regel für zweifach
geimpft bekommen das wäre in einem monat
mehr tempo fordern da einige
das dauert einfach zu lange die
diskussionen laufen überall
man sieht es die einzelnen bundesländer
treffen übergangsregelungen die sind
unterschiedlich das kann so nicht sein
das war nicht so gewollt der bund wollte
ein einheitliches verfahren haben jetzt
ist er in der pflicht auch dieses
verfahren schnell durchzuführen
grundrechte dürften nicht länger
eingeschränkt werden für menschen mit
vollen impfschutz da sind sich viele
einig dass wie das wan sorgt aber weiter
für eine menge unsicherheit überall in
deutschland blicken wir auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen dort zeigt sich
ein leichter rückgang
das robert koch institut meldet 22 1231
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 2653 weniger als vergangenen
mittwoch 312 todesfälle kam hinzu
die sieben tage incidents singt auf 100
60,6 vor allem in großstädten zeigt der
blick auf die inzidenz 'nen in den
verschiedenen stadtteilen die faktoren
armut und herkunft spielen in der
pandemie offenbar eine wichtige bisher
noch nicht so beachtete rolle
die ansteckungsgefahr ist größer wenn
viele menschen auf engem raum leben in
prekären verhältnissen arbeiten und wenn
sprache und kultur die vermittlung von
regeln behindern
mellies sehr schilka zeigt das am
beispiel von köln und duisburg duisburg
marxloh ein sozial benachteiligter
stadtteile hier liegt die instanz zahl
aktuell bei über 250 im reicheren süden
ist die instanz deutlich geringer
die gründe dafür sind vielfältig
manchmal werden regeln nicht eingehalten
wie ein metzgerei besitzer beobachtet
ist vor keine abstand eine maske immer
lauf und ähnliches problem in köln im
sozialen brennpunkt chorweiler liegt die
letzte ermittelte instituts bei über 520
20 kilometer weiter im villenviertel
hahnwald bei null
eine aktuelle studie bestätigt dieses
problem stadtteil die eine sehr dichte
bebauung haben wo es viele einwohner pro
gebäude gibt wo es generell auf einfach
männer hochhaus oder mehrfamilienhaus
besiedlung gibt wo auch die
arbeitslosenquoten höher sind und die
kaufkraft schwächer ist dass dort in
diesen regionen geben die
infektionszahlen höher sind strukturell
benachteiligte stadtteile werden häufig
von menschen mit migrationsgeschichte
bewohnt doch das ist nicht
ausschlaggebend für hohe
infektionszahlen das wetter spielt eine
rolle viele menschen möchten raus die
diskussion rund um ausgangssperre tetra
ist ermüdend und wenn sie mit 56
menschen in einem kleinen in beengten
wohnverhältnissen wohnen
das sind glaube ich gerade die sozialen
unterschiede die hier eine wichtige
rolle spielen als der ethnische
hintergrund viele städte versuchen jetzt
gegenzusteuern
sie wollen auf die menschen in den
brennpunkten zu geben mit vermehrten
tests und mobilen im teams wen corona am
härtesten trifft darum geht es auch um
halb acht bei zdf heute live in der
heute app auf youtube und auf facebook
es ist ein spagat zwischen wirtschaft
und menschenrechten der das verhältnis
von deutschland zu china bestimmt auch
heute bei den konsultationen beider
regierungen
einerseits ist china der größte
exportmarkt für deutsche unternehmen mit
einem volumen von 95,9 milliarden euro
besonders gefragt autos made in germany
vier von zehn neuwagen werden in der
volksrepublik verkauft andererseits
unterdrückt das land systematisch
minderheiten und protestbewegungen
patricia biedermeier berichtet
können er anfangen sehr gerne sie sind
ja sie sind ja gastgeber es sind
ungewöhnliche zeiten pandemie zeiten
china ist digitaler gastgeber beim
sechsten treffen dieser art zahlreiche
absichtserklärungen zur verstärkten
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit auch
beim klimaschutz wurden unterzeichnet
doch bei allen wirtschaftlichen
interessen es sind gespräche mit einem
immer stärker auftretenden immer
autoritäre rim und demokratischen staat
es gibt jenseits der notwendigen
partnerschaft und kooperation mit china
beispielsweise im klimaschutz bereich
viele punkte bei denen man mit den
chinesen noch deutlichere worte finden
muss bei der menschenrechtsfrage beim
völkerrechts bruch in hongkong etwa für
diese auseinandersetzung um die werte
über das was recht menschenrechte
völkerrecht ist die müssen wir offensiv
führen 2020 hat china hongkongs
völkerrechtlich garantierte
unabhängigkeit de facto beendet und auch
der umgang mit der muslimischen
minderheit der uiguren wird immer wieder
kritisiert heute auch von der kanzlerin
zu unserer partnerschaft gehört auch
dass wir schwierige themen ansprechen
und alles auch auf den tisch legen
können
dabei spielt das thema menschenrechte
traditionsgemäß in unseren gesprächen
immer wieder eine rolle hier gibt es
auch meinungsverschiedenheiten die
gegenseitige nichteinmischung in innere
angelegenheiten sei zu respektieren so
die deutliche republik man sollte hier
unnötige störungen beseitigen und an
einer win win zusammenarbeit festhalten
dann können sich unsere beziehungen
gesund und stabil entwickeln win win das
heißt für die kanzlerin möglichst bald
wieder einen menschenrechtsdialog für
china dagegen wirtschaftlich noch größer
und erfolgreicher zu werden als sie es
eh schon sind ja die situation kommt
einem irgendwie bekannt vor ulf röller
um die menschenrechte steht es schlecht
aber deutschland will auch nicht auf die
geschäfte mit china verzichten
das wissen die chinesen natürlich ja als
man vor zehn jahren mit dem regierungs
dialog zwischen deutschland und china
angefangen hat da gab es die hoffnung
bei der bundesregierung dass man durch
interesse intensivere handelsbeziehungen
wird
beziehung eben doch auch das politische
system in china vielleicht beeinflussen
könnte
das gegenteil ist der fall china ist
nicht freier geworden in diesen zehn
jahren sondern ein wesentlicher
autoritäre russland china ist eine sehr
selbstbewusste diktatur und strafft
jeden ab der sie kritisiert man kann das
deutlich daran erkennen wenn es kein
bart findet kein deutschen manager der
es wagt china wegen seiner
menschenrechtspolitik werde weniger zu
kritisieren weil das eben
wirtschaftsprobleme mit sich bringen
würde
china will also nicht nur die meinung in
dem eigenen land kontrollieren sondern
eben auch bei uns china kritische
stimmen verstummen lassen
man kann sagen nach zehn jahren ein
fazit es war gut für die wirtschaft aber
es war schlecht für die menschenrechte
eine ernüchternde bilanz vielen dank
dafür ulf nach italien
dort hat das parlament mit großer
mehrheit einen milliardenschweren corona
wiederaufbau plan verabschiedet nach der
abgeordnetenkammer stimmte auch der
senat für das konjunkturprogramm
es ist 220 milliarden euro schwer das
geld kommt größtenteils von der
eu-regierungschefs draghi plant damit
unter anderem investitionen in die
infrastruktur in grüne energie und in
die digitalisierung gut vier monate lang
haben die niederländer in einem strengen
lockdown gelebt die extrem hohe inzidenz
konnte das allerdings kaum drücken
selig derzeit bei 296 also etwa doppelt
so hoch wie in deutschland
trotzdem sieht es ab heute in den
städten so aus offene restaurant
terrassen offene geschäfte einen ersten
schritt zurück zur normalität nannte
premier mark rutte die beschlossenen
lockerungen vor denen wissenschaftler
allerdings nachdrücklich warnen ampel
gellinek dass prinz hendrik in venlo ist
voll endlich wieder draußen sitzen und
kaffee trinken
seit heute mittag um 12 dürfen die
terrassen wieder öffnen
auch shoppen ohne termin ist in den
niederlanden erlaubt der appell an
grenzgänger trotzdem zu hause zu bleiben
verhallt ungehört
vor einer woche hatte die
niederländische regierung unter premier
mark rutte die lockerungen beschlossen
auch die abendliche ausgangssperre ist
nun aufgehoben
trotz fast doppelt so hohe
infektionszahlen die in deutschland im
krankenhaus von breda in südholland
haben ärzte und pfleger keine zeit
darüber nachzudenken die intensivstation
ist von 24 auf 39 betten aufgestockt
worden und schon wieder sind fast alle
belegt schon gibt es überlegungen
patienten nach deutschland zu verlegen
die erschöpften ärzte in breda schütteln
den kopf über die entscheidung der
regierung ja doch verbessert wir sind
fassungslos
das passt nicht zur situation in unseren
krankenhäusern viele kollegen und
experten haben der regierung dringend
geraten nicht zu lockern
aber die entscheidung wurde offenbar
aufgrund anderer interessen getroffen
das ist nicht richtig in den ganzen
niederlanden sind nur noch wenige
intensivbetten frei schon droht der
sogenannte code schwarz dann muss eine
kommission entscheiden welche patienten
noch behandelt werden können und welche
nicht
die regierung hat offenbar dem druck der
straße nachgegeben
bei der gestrigen party zum geburtstag
des königs half weder polizei noch
bußgeld die menschen feierten unerlaubt
und ausgelassen ohne maske ohne abstand
die warnen mediziner hoffen unterdessen
dass sie nicht recht behalten
in der lettischen hauptstadt riga sind
bei einem brand in einem hostel acht
menschen ums leben gekommen
das feuer war am frühen morgen in dem
sechsstöckigen gebäude im zentrum der
stadt ausgebrochen
es war illegal und ohne den nötigen
brandschutz als untergrund vermietet
worden
die opfer sollen überwiegend
ausländische studenten seien die schule
einerseits manchmal tatort
sexualisierter gewalt gegen kinder
andererseits aber auch auf zufluchtsort
vor dem missbrauch in der familie
zwei oft verdrängte wirklichkeiten die
betroffene angehörige und lehrer innen
jahrzehntelang wie einen schweren
rucksack mit sich herumtragen eine
bundesweite kampagne ruft sie jetzt auf
sich von dieser last zu befreien
henriette de maizière es ist eine last
aus der kindheit die viele mit sich
herumtragen sexualisierte gewalt in der
schulzeit auch für jannis labs elf jahre
war er ein argloser junge als ich ein
lehrer an ihm verging
man hat ja auch gewisses vertrauen
aufgebaut also irgendwie so dass schon
nichts böses so dass dementsprechend lag
ich dann halt und er hat sich ja quasi
auch bei nicht befriedigt dann bis er
dann irgendwann fertig war
den gestank werde auf jeden fall nicht
vergessen ein spot mit schauspielerinnen
und schauspielern fordert betroffene auf
sich zu melden
denn an dem erlebten tragen viele schwer
oft ein leben lang unter dem motto
werden sie los was sie nicht loslässt
startet die unabhängige kommission zur
aufklärung sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs
diesen aufruf für betroffene ist es ganz
wichtig dass sie dass ihnen zugehört
wird und dass ihre geschichte ihre
erlebnisse ihre erfahrungen auch ihr
wissen eingebracht werden kann in unsere
anstrengungen kinder und jugendliche
heute besser zu schützen
die geschichte erzählen um sich von der
last zu befreien
jannis labs ist diesen schritt gegangen
leute sollten halt wissen das ist halt
schon stellen gibt die einem zuhören
können und dann noch helfen können dass
es besser wird
der spot ruft betroffene auf wenn sie in
ihrer kindheit oder jugend sexueller
gewalt in der schule ausgesetzt waren
sich zu melden
seit jahren setzt sich bundeskanzlerin
merkel für die rechte der sinti und roma
ein
dafür wurde sie nun ausgezeichnet mit
dem europäischen bürgerrechts preis der
sinti und roma der preis sei
auszeichnung und ansporn zugleich sagte
merkel bei der digitalen verleihung im
kampf gegen antiziganismus gebe es noch
viel zu tun
sortiert ist die auszeichnung mit 15.000
euro
sie sollen auf wunsch der kanzlerin an
organisationen gehen die sich für die
belange der sinti und roma einsetzen und
damit sind wir beim sport und kommen zur
fußball champions league
da gab es ja gestern abend das erste
halbfinal hinspiel zwischen real madrid
und dem fc chelsea am ende stand's 1 1
eine gute ausgangsposition für die
londoner im rückspiel dabei war für
thomas tuchel und seine blues sogar noch
mehr drin
klitschnass und nur so halb zufrieden so
endete der abend für thomas tuchel was
auch an werners vergebener 100 prozent
chance in der neunten minute lag das
ausland hat lange zu weinen oder sich zu
beklagen beides nützt nichts millionen
menschen haben gerade größere sorgen als
seine vergebene torchancen davis werners
sturmkollege politik der ex-dortmunder
machte es nur fünf minuten später dann
besser und brachte die gäste von der
insel verdient in führung
den ausgleich für real erzielte karim
benzema nach einer knappen halben stunde
das 1 1 durch den franzosen lässt beide
teams aufs endspiel hoffen für tuchel
wäre es sogar das zweite innerhalb von
nur neun monaten junior nagelsmann geht
jesse marsch soll com nach
zdf-informationen hat rb leipzig schnell
einen neuen trainer gefunden
der 47 jährige us amerikaner arbeitet
zurzeit noch als coach bei rb salzburg
und hat dort im letzten jahr
meisterschaft und pokal gewonnen
marsch war schon von 2018 bis 2019
co-trainer in leipzig zuvor hatte er die
new york red bulls zu einem spitzenteam
geformt
gelungener start von alexander zverev
beim atp sandplatzturnier in münchen
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
besiegte den litauer ricardas berankis
mit 6 2 6 4 6 4 und zieht damit souverän
ins viertelfinale ein
der zuletzt heftig schmerzen der
ellenbogen soll sich kaum noch bemerkbar
gemacht haben bei alexander zverev
die nummer 89 der weltbank ist ein
dankbarer gegner zu manchmal noch
holprigen einstieg nach zwei wochen
spielpause satzgewinne nummer eins mit
einem trockenen us zum 62 als sein
gegner im zweiten satz gleich zieht
umgehend das re break mit einem
perfekten longline ball und wenig später
drei matchbälle von denen der zweite
sitzt sein sechstes 18 624 der erste
schritt zum dritten titelgewinn in
münchen
das lösungswort nein noch nicht ich habe
auch noch weiter zum sport und zwar in
diesem fitnessgerät stehen brüsseler
atomium mit genau 500 sechs stufen seit
heute kennt der belgische bmx vize
weltmeister peter geis jede einzelne
davon allesamt ist er abgefahren um geld
für menschen zu sammeln die sich nach
unfall oder krankheit zurück ins leben
kämpfen müssen
seit singen für einen guten zweck
und hier sind die lottozahlen am
mittwoch
sie lauten 12 13 21 23 31 46 und die
superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
nach viel sonne kommt ab heute nacht
regen alles vom wetter gleich von katja
honnefer das war es von uns im
heute-journal freut sich heute christian
sievers auf sie und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder wenn sie denn mögen einen
gemütlichen abend wünsche ich tschüss
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren der
oberrhein geografisch ist das der rhein
zwischen bingen und basel führt zurzeit
oft niedrigwasser wie hier bei worms das
wird sich jetzt allerdings ändern denn
das tief christian verdrängt das
sonnenhof sandra weiter nach osten und
es bringt auch regen mit bis zum ende
des wochenendes können deutschlandweit
so zehn bis dreißig örtlich sogar 50
liter regen pro quadratmeter fallen
es beginnt schon heute abend mit dem
regen und der zieht im laufe der nacht
weiter nach nordosten erreicht bis zum
frühen morgen auch die elbe im äußersten
norden und osten bleibt es dagegen noch
trocken die temperaturen dort sinken auf
7 bis 4 grad sonst wird das aber eine
milde nacht hier im südwesten da geht es
nur auf 12 bis 8 grad runter das ist die
erste frostfreien acht seit vielen
echten morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen in norddeutschland
meist 10 bis 14 grad sonst werden 14 bis
18 grad erreicht und in niederbayern 20
grad das wetter ist morgen dreigeteilt
in norddeutschland fällt viel regen und
es gibt auch mal kurze gewitter zwischen
den lagern und dem erzgebirge wird es
freundlicher südlich der donau aber
müssen wir uns auf einige schauer
einstellen in den nächsten tagen geht es
wechselhaft weiter erst am sonntag wird
es aber deutlich kühler
schönen abend noch